hey rich my question is about the topic
of money
as a child i was thought that money is a
variable that has a significant
influence on our choices how are you
going to pay for it
was my parents first question when i
would talk about my dreams
in finding ultra rich you share a moment
when you had left your law practice
was waiting to get traction as an author
and was on the brink of financial ruin
how are you able to maintain the pursuit
of your dream and resist the urge to
return to your law practice
exclusively just to provide for your
family how would you advise others to
think about money
especially if it creates an obstacles to
making change i want to thank you guys
very much for your valuable insight in
your podcast and especially
this particular format this interactive
format makes it much easier and
much better to be able to interact have
you guys having a great day
bye thanks greg that's a great question
i think it's an important question no
don't um
i want to preface what i'm going to say
by saying that uh i am not
telling anyone what to do or not to do
nor am i giving any
financial advice but i will share
a little bit of my experience and and i
think first of all
i'm with you i grew up in the same way
um
[Music]
being told you know when i would give
voice to anything aspirational or
inspirate you know sort of
aspirational for my life um being
brought
back down to earth with a heavy dose
of kind of prudent reality
so i'm on i'm on your wavelength greg
but what i've come to think the way i've
come to think about this
as is as when i think about money
as this balance or this dance between
responsibility or prudence on the one
hand
and on the other hand understanding that
that money is just
energy you know money is of course
a variable that is going to influence
choice
but the key
i think first and foremost is
understanding that we don't live in a
zero-sum
game and that by adopting a mindset of
universal abundance will help you
really get that money just like
everything else is this
waveform this energy something that in
my experience
um tends to be less important and and
flow a little bit more freely when your
life is oriented not around the pursuit
of it
but rather the pursuit of of purpose
it is true that that uh you know i grew
up
with parents who were hammering a
similar message into me
and i oriented my life around that
perspective and i found that in so
doing it didn't matter how much money i
made i never had
any of it because i was so out of
alignment with a greater
sense of purpose that i would compensate
for that lack of fulfillment
by spending whatever i had to kind of
fill that hole so i was chasing the
dragon in a way that i was never going
to get on top of it and it was only by
kind of crashing into a wall with all of
that
and flaming out that i was able to
reconfigure my relationship to money and
i had to do it through an extended
period of hardship where we didn't have
any
and that forced me to get really clear
on what my needs were
and what was most important to me and
what my values were
and i made a commitment to pursue those
values irrespective of
any kind of financial reward and i will
say there were plenty of moments where
my faith was tested and
if julie had not had my back i very well
would have you know scampered back and
tried to get
a job that would pay the bills because
it was very difficult it was
emasculating
at times very humiliating didn't you
even have to take
some like small kind of law
gigs at one point when you were when
things weren't going well i did
i did i was i was sort of practicing law
as i was writing finding ultra but
when that book came out i was like i'm
not do i i drew a line in the sand i was
like i'm not doing it anymore okay
i'm trusting that this is going to open
up the door to a new path
and it took a long time you know the
phone just didn't ring for a long time
and there were
there were there were months where we
were scrambling like nobody's business
and having cars repossessed and having
our trash bins taken away
right being unable to you know figure
out how we were going to
feed the kids that night it was really
really
difficult my faith was
tremendously tested julie you know i
i look back on it and i don't know how
she had the fortitude to like have my
back
in that period of time but she did and
she would constantly hammer home this
idea of like
the only way out is forward like you
can't go backwards like you've come too
far
the answers you seek are ahead of you
and i'm with you and we're together and
we'll figure it out and money comes and
money goes
but what's important here is you finding
your voice and figuring
out you know how you're going to move
forward in the world and that's like a
precious
gift and you know i'm here to help you
honor that
and that takes an extraordinary human
being it does that it really does it's
not the average person it's not like oh
behind every great man there's a great
woman like no she was
like the jedi well i was like panicking
in the corner
right you know and so right without her
none of this
happens um but i think because we went
without for such a long period of time
and we were compelled to like live in
the moment
and it really did reframe my
relationship with money and these
decisions that i made about how i wanted
to live my life
were decoupled from
any pursuit of financial gain like i i
made that barter i was like i don't care
this is the way i want to go this is
what makes me happy this is what's
fulfilling this is where
i see promise and opportunity even if i
don't see it right now
and it didn't have anything to do with
financial remuneration
um so you removed that completely from
the mind by the equation by like
removing that
yeah in some weird spiritual equation
i created space for it to come in in a
different way
and by continuing to trust my instincts
and
follow my curiosity and double down on
these values as kind of the foundation
or the architecture for what i do
professionally
i'm suddenly you know it's ridiculous
but like i make way more money now than
i ever i never thought i would ever have
money like i just made peace with that i
will never have money
that's fine and now i've got all this
money
like i'm like technically i'm like rich
which is [ __ ] crazy because you're
rich
too like i you know it's like but it
doesn't
i don't think about it i don't think
about how much money is coming
in my spending habits haven't really
changed
i don't really do anything differently
like my whole relationship with money
is different like i just hold it loosely
and so i don't know how that's
instructive to somebody
else other than to say that if i've
discovered anything through this journey
it's that
it's that the key
is figuring out what gets you excited in
the morning
and with that you have this opportunity
and this responsibility to get clear
on on what your
how to how to orient like purpose
premised on those values
and whatever it is that is lighting you
up the more that you continue to do it
the universe starts to orient around you
like it congeals around you to provide
opportunities and i think over time
those opportunities lead to some kind of
vocational situation that will allow you
to meet your needs
yeah i'm not saying you're going to get
rich or anything like that
but you will find yourself in a
situation where work doesn't feel
like work because
it's something that you would be doing
anyway yeah
does that make sense it does i think
it's great and i think jedi julie
deserves to be an action figure she does
we know people who make action figures
yeah she'd be good
yeah i think the other thing too is is
you know on that note of
here's my dream well how are you going
to pay for it all i can tell you is that
every dream that i've realized i
couldn't pay for
right if i'd set out at the beginning to
say well i have this thing how am i
going to pay for it i never would have
gotten out of the gate
the thing is you have to just start
pursuing it and like i said the universe
arranges itself around you
to provide the support that you need it
might not look like what you would like
it to look like and it might not be as
as much as you would like it to be but
generally it allows you to take one more
forward step
like that's it you don't get the
blueprint you don't get to see where
this is leading or how it's all going to
play out
you just don't get to see the whole
picture all you get
on the daily is a test can you take that
next step your faith is tested
and i think every time you show up
to pass that test there's something that
happens
in the universe where it says okay he
passed that test we'll give him a little
we'll throw him a little loose change
see
see if he can pass the next test and
also the conversations around you
including from if your parents are
are around and still not just in your
head but in your life
um those conversations start to change
too but it could take
many years could take five years could
take ten years but the conversations all
of a sudden you'll notice one day
and it won't be about you know can he do
it or
you should get a job or blah blah blah
it'll be uh
you know conversations about pride like
you know right
because when you're in it you cannot you
cannot
expect the support of people like that
they're just not going to like i i
everybody thought i was insane right
people were telling julie like what's
the matter with you you got to divorce
this guy like he's
lost his he's completely lost it yeah so
that's the way that it is when you're in
the midst of it and that makes it even
harder to find your footing because you
start to question yourself like maybe i
am insane everybody else thinks i'm
insane
of course when it all works out then
it's like oh we're so proud of you and
we saw it all the time
we supported you they forget that they
were the ones saying how are you going
to pay for that
pay for that thing in the beginning and
that's just the way that it's wired
that's the way it goes
and it's not for everybody like it was
really hard
i'm not wishing this journey on people
not everybody is cut out for
it if you're happy in your job and you
have a profession and your goal
is to provide for your family and have
barbecues on the weekends
that's great i'm not telling people to
quit their job
i'm speaking to the person who's got
that yearning in their soul where they
feel like they just can't do it one more
day and they have this
sense or this calling that there's
something out there and all i'm saying
is
listen to that pay attention to it try
to put a little wind in that sail
you know put a little fertilizer in that
soil
and be open to where it might lead you
and pay attention
[Music]
you